Danke für eure positiven Reaktionen
zu meiner Reportage
"Mythos Matterhorn".
Es sind sehr viele
positive Kommentare eingegangen,
was mich sehr freut.
Es kamen auch viele Fragen,
die rege diskutiert wurden.
Ich möchte mir Zeit nehmen, um
auf einige eurer Fragen einzugehen.
Als erste wurde diese Frage gestellt:
Für mich war das sowieso
eine aussergewöhnliche Situation.
Ich war nicht nur in der Hörnlihütte,
um auf den Berg zu steigen,
sondern mit dem Wissen
und der Einstellung,
dass ich eine Reportage drehte.
Ich hatte so viele andere Gedanken -
ich musste an den Ton denken,
ich musste darüber nachdenken,
welche Fragen ich stellen würde.
Ich musste auch gut auf Anjan hören
und schauen, wie er reagierte,
um zu wissen,
wie ich ihn nehmen konnte.
Das sind Dinge,
die einem Journalisten
immer im Hinterkopf herumschwirren.
Darum hatte ich keine Zeit,
um mich
auf die Situation dort einzulassen
oder das wirklich zu merken.
Ich war froh, dass Anjan mir sagte:
"Dann musst du da sein,
dann gehen wir einfach los."
Von daher:
Nein, es war nicht so stressig,
wie es vielleicht ausgesehen hat.
Aber das ist bei jedem individuell.
Ich kann mir gut vorstellen,
dass viele sehr nervös sind,
die am Morgen an dieser Tür stehen
und sich in der Hierarchie einreihen.
Viele trainieren lange und
für viele ist das ein Lebenstraum,
der an diesem Tag X
in Erfüllung geht.
Darum ist es nachvollziehbar,
dass es ein Stressfaktor sein kann.
Eine weitere Frage
kommt von LordTeddy0:
Sehr aufmerksam von LordTeddy0.
Er hat völlig recht, da ist uns
ein kleiner Fehler unterlaufen.
Zwischen den beiden Szenen
mit Steigeisen
hat sich
eine GoPro-Aufnahme eingeschlichen,
die etwas weiter unten
auf dem Grat gemacht wurde.
Du hast völlig recht.
Man klettert hoch bis zu jenem Punkt,
ab dem man sich mehrheitlich
in Eis und Schnee befindet.
Dort zieht man die Steigeisen an
und geht dann mit den Steigeisen
bis zum Gipfel.
Man zieht sie natürlich nicht
zwischendurch aus.
Man kommt wieder runter, bis man
wieder mehrheitlich im Fels ist,
zieht sie aus
und geht zur Hütte zurück.
Danke für diesen Hinweis.
Das ist auch sehr gut beobachtet.
Diese Frage kann man sich natürlich
bei allen Bergen stellen.
Wieso muss man da hoch?
Man kann sie sich von unten ansehen.
Ja, was soll ich sagen?
Die Berge ziehen mich
und viele andere magisch an.
Über Sinn und Unsinn
kann man natürlich immer diskutieren,
aber es liegt irgendwo tief in uns
drin, dass wir da hinauf wollen.
Wir suchen das Abenteuer -
zumindest ist das bei mir so.
Es ist etwas ganz anderes,
wenn man dort oben steht und weiss,
man steht auf dem Berg,
den man 30 Jahre angeschaut hat.
Eine weitere Frage kommt von Janik:
Ja, der Kameramann war mit einem
zusätzlichen Bergführer unterwegs.
Kameramann Thomas Senf
ist selbst diplomierter Bergführer.
Er leitet oft selbst Touren
und hat viele Gäste,
Er ist aber auch als Kameramann
und Fotograf in den Bergen tätig.
Er hätte nicht unbedingt
einen Bergführer gebraucht,
aber es ist immer besser, wenn man
sich auf etwas konzentrieren kann -
in diesem Fall auf die Kamera -,
und den Sicherheitsaspekt einem
Bergführerkollegen abgeben kann.
Anjan, es freut mich,
dass wir dich zuschalten konnten.
Ich habe eine Frage für dich
von Nico:
Das ist
ein reiner Sicherheitsaspekt.
Das Seil verbindet dich und mich,
damit ich dich v.a.
an schwierigen Stellen sichern kann.
Wir haben es ja so gemacht, dass
ich dir sagte, du solltest warten.
Dann band ich dich
an einem Haken oder einem Stift fest,
kletterte hoch
und konnte dich dann nachsichern.
Das andere
ist das sog. Gehen am kurzen Seil.
Das ist eine Technik,
die Bergführer lernen,
damit man relativ effizient,
aber doch sehr sicher vorankommt.
Das Seil ist immer irgendwo
um einen Stein gewickelt
oder in meiner Hand eng an dir.
Wenn du stolperst oder ausrutschst,
nimmst du so
schon gar keine Geschwindigkeit auf.
Je länger das Seil, desto mehr
Geschwindigkeit nehme ich auf,
desto mehr freien Fall habe ich.
- Ja.
Wenn ich das Seil zu dir
nicht gut spannen würde,
wir viel Schlappseil hätten
und du stürzen würdest,
würdest du quasi
mit vollem Gewicht ins Seil fallen
und ich könnte dich
nicht mehr halten.
Aber es bleibt ein Restrisiko,
dass ich dich mitreissen könnte.
Sehe ich das richtig?
Es ist ganz klar, dass bei dieser
Technik ein Restrisiko bleibt.
Es gibt auch Situationen, in denen
man das nicht so machen darf,
nämlich wenn das Sturzpotenzial
sehr gross ist.
Also bei schwierigen Stellen
wie z.B. Firnflanken.
Dort ist es sehr heikel.
Darum nimmt der Bergführer
meistens nur einen Gast mit.
Einen Gast
kann der Bergführer halten.
Bei zweien ist das
eigentlich schon unrealistisch.
Aber auch bei einem Gast
ist es sehr wichtig,
dass der Bergführer immer 100%ig
konzentriert bei der Sache ist.
Ein User schreibt:
Es geht um die Stelle, an der ich
ausrutsche und ins Seil falle,
du mich aber eben
am kurzen Seil festhältst.
Ich persönlich habe das
als nicht so absolut erlebt.
Ich glaube nicht, dass ich ohne Anjan
in den sicheren Tod gestürzt wäre.
Ich hätte
noch einen Ausfallschritt gemacht,
aber es stimmt:
Anjan hatte mich am kurzen Seil.
In meiner Erinnerung ist es so,
dass ich diesen Ausfallschritt
noch hätte machen können.
Ich hätte mich gut auffangen können,
weil da noch Boden war.
Anjan, kannst du dich daran erinnern?
Wie hast du das erlebt?
Du hattest schon Zug auf dem Seil.
Du hast mich gespürt.
Das sind eben
genau diese brenzligen Situationen.
Da ist es zwingend, dass der
Bergführer seinen Job richtig macht,
damit du in dem Moment
keine Geschwindigkeit aufnimmst.
Wenn dein "Ausfallschritt"
vielleicht nicht funktioniert,
bist du draussen in der Luft.
Dann ist es schon zu spät.
Wenn du mal in der Luft bist,
kann ich dich nicht mehr auffangen.
In Zermatt kostet die Besteigung
ziemlich genau 1'600 Fr.
Da sind die Übernachtung dabei,
das Ticket nach Schwarzsee,
das Essen und der Bergführer.
Das klingt nach sehr viel Geld.
Andererseits plädierst du dafür, dass
man nur Bergführer hochsteigen soll.
Ist das kein Widerspruch?
Jein. Es klingt nach sehr viel.
Das kann man rechnen, wie man will.
Der Bergführer
geht am Vortag zur Hütte,
d.h., er verlässt am Nachmittag
um ca. 15 Uhr sein Zuhause.
Er übernachtet oben mit dem Gast
und ist am nächsten Tag 8-10 Std.
mit dem Gast am Berg unterwegs.
Er trägt auch
ein erhebliches Risiko mit.
Dann kommt er zurück
und steigt von der Hütte herunter.
Wenn man das addiert,
sind das 24 Std.
Dann muss man die Übernachtung
und alles andere abziehen.
Wenn man das auf
einen Stundenlohn umrechnen würde,
ist es wohl nicht mehr so viel.
Wenn du heute ein Auto
zum Mechaniker bringen
oder den Elektriker
ins Haus lassen musst ...
Da sind wir
relativ günstig unterwegs.
Ich habe noch eine weitere Frage
für dich von Kevin.
* Anjan lacht. *
Der beste Tipp ist sicher,
mit einem Bergführer zu gehen.
Das haben wir ja diskutiert.
Ich glaube, man hat im Film
auch gesehen, warum.
Es gibt natürlich
viele hervorragende Alpinisten,
die das locker allein machen können.
So einer
ist eigentlich schon vorbereitet.
Wenn einer das wirklich
solo machen wollte,
sollte er nicht vorbereitet sein
wie wie der deutsche Kollege,
den wir bei
unserer Besteigung getroffen haben,
sondern wirklich gut vorbereitet -
Kondition, Technik,
der Weg und alles.
Mein Tipp ist auch:
Nimm einen Bergführer,
dann kannst du es geniessen.
Der Berg ist technisch
nicht so schwer.
Es gibt schwierigere Wände und Berge.
Aber es ist Wahnsinn,
wie schwer der Weg zu finden ist.
Nur schon dafür lohnt es sich,
jemanden dabeizuhaben,
der schon 200-, 100-
oder 50-mal oben war.
Dann kann man es geniessen.
Die Ausbildung
zum Rettungsspezialisten
kann man nach Abschluss
der Bergführerprüfungen machen.
Bei uns ist es so, dass man zwingend
Bergführer sein muss.
In Regionen,
wo es z.T. keine Bergführer gibt,
kann man das auch ohne machen.
Dann muss man aber
mit einem Eignungstest zeigen,
dass man wirklich
gebirgstauglich ist.
Dann kann man die Zusatzausbildung
über mehrere Module
im Verlauf
von etwa drei Jahren machen.
Wie sieht's bei dir aus?
Hattest du schon Verletzungen?
Ich weiss nicht, ob sich die Frage
auf dein Bergsteigertum
oder deine Rettungseinsätze bezieht.
Klopf auf Holz.
Bei den Rettungseinsätzen
hatte ich noch nie etwas.
Als junger Bergführer geriet ich am
Matterhorn mal in einen Steinschlag,
der von anderen ausgelöst worden
war, die zu früh gestartet waren.
Sie kletterten oberhalb von uns,
und da fiel das ganze Gerümpel
auf mich und meinen Gast hinunter.
Was hast du dir dabei zugezogen?
Ich hatte Kopfverletzungen,
Schürfwunden -
ich hatte ziemliches Glück,
denn ich fiel dabei auch ins Seil.
Gott sei Dank
verfing es sich an einer Kante,
sonst wäre das wahrscheinlich
nicht so glimpflich ausgegangen.
Argus schreibt:
Ja, gut,
darüber kann man diskutieren.
Klar kann man sich
eine andere Beschäftigung suchen,
aber es gehört eben auch
Passion dazu,
und es gibt viele,
die einen Bergführer buchen wollen.
Es funktioniert ja.
Man versucht ja nicht, den Berg
in einen Klettersteig zu verwandeln,
sondern einfach das Abenteuer
oder die Besteigung
so sicher wie möglich zu machen.
"Wie sieht es eigentlich
bezüglich Schuhen aus?"
"Reicht Kategorie B/C
(bedingt steigeisenfest)
oder braucht man fürs Horn
mind. Kategorie C?"
Ich bin der Meinung,
dass man am Matterhorn
auch bei trockenen
und guten Verhältnissen
mindestens Kategorie C haben sollte.
Im oberen Teil
braucht man meistens Steigeisen.
Im Frühsommer oder Herbst,
wenn viel Schnee liegt
und man die Steigeisen
länger tragen muss,
ist Kategorie D sicher wichtig.
Aber ob C oder D - die Schuhe
sind heutzutage so gemacht,
dass das kein Problem ist.
Aber sicher nicht mit einfachen
Turn- oder Trekkingschuhen gehen,
die nur bedingt steigeisenfest sind.
Im Film sagst du, Anjan, dass das
der tödlichste Berg der Welt ist.
Eine Frage ist:
Kannst du etwas dazu sagen?
Es ist so: Im Vergleich
gibt es keinen anderen Berg,
der so viele Todesfälle verzeichnet.
(Matthias) In absoluten Zahlen.
- In absoluten Zahlen.
Auch wenn man z.B. den Mount Everest
in den letzten 30 Jahren nimmt,
der sicher eine sehr hohe Zahl
von Todesfällen ausweist,
sind gesamthaft immer noch
weniger Menschen gestorben
als am Matterhorn.
Wenn man von nur einem Berg spricht,
gibt es im Verhältnis
keinen anderen Berg,
der so viele Todesopfer
gefordert hat.
Das war's für den Moment.
Wenn ihr weitere Fragen habt,
schreibt sie in die Kommentare.
Ich versuche sie zu beantworten,
so gut es geht.
Wenn ihr weitere
solche Reportagen sehen wollt,
abonniert den Kanal
und aktiviert die Glocke.